i have to bring up uh joe rogan i don't
know if you know who he is i do he's a
podcaster comedian fighting commentator
and
my now friend an ivor mechton uh
believer too yes that is the question i
have to ask you about
uh he has gotten some flack in the
mainstream media for not getting
vaccinated and when he got coveted
recently taking ivermectin as part of a
cocktail of treatments
the nih actually has a nice page on
ivermectin
saying quote there's insufficient
evidence to recommend either for or
against the use of ivermectin for the
treatment of covin19
results from adequately powered
well-designed and well-conducted
clinical trials are needed to provide
more specific evidence-based guidance on
the role of ivermectin in the treatment
of covenant 19.
so let me ask why do you think there has
been so much attack on joe rogan and
anyone else
that's talking about ivermectin when
there's insufficient evidence for or
against
well let's unpack that
first of all i think the concerns about
joe are not limited to his taking
ivermectin
much more seriously his being fairly
publicly negative about vaccines
at a time where people are dying
700 000 people have died from covet 19
estimates
by kaiser or at least 100 000 of those
were unnecessary deaths of unvaccinated
people and for joe to promote that
further even as this uh
pandemic rages through our population
is simply irresponsible
so yeah the ivermectin is just one other
twist obviously ivermectin has been
controversial for months and months
the reason that it got particular
attention is because of the way in which
it seemed to have captured the
imagination of a lot of people and to
the point where they were taking doses
that were intended for livestock
and some of them got pretty sick as a
result from overdosing on this stuff
that was not good judgment
the drug itself remains uncertain
there's a recent review that looks at
all of the studies of ivermectin
and basically concludes that it probably
doesn't work
we are running a study right now i
looked at that data this morning
uh in a trial called active six which is
one of the ones that my public-private
partnership is running we're up to about
400 patients who've been randomized to
ivermectin or placebo
and should know
perhaps as soon as a month from now in a
very carefully controlled trial did it
help or did it not so there will be an
answer
coming back to joe
again i don't think the fact that he
took divermectin and hoping it might
work
is that big a knock against him it's
more the conveying of we don't trust
what science says which is vaccines are
going to save your life we're going to
trust what's on the internet that says
ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine really
do work even though the scientific
community says probably not so let me
push back in that a little bit
so he doesn't he doesn't say let's not
listen to science
he doesn't say the vaccine don't get
vaccinated
he says it's okay
to ask questions i'm okay with that how
risky is the vaccine for certain
populations
what are the uh benefits and risks
there's other friends of joe
and
friends of mine like sam harris
who says if you look at the data
it's obvious that the benefits outweigh
the risks
and what joe says
is yes but let's
still openly talk about risks and he
often brings up anecdotal evidence of
people who've had
uh highly negative effects from
vaccines science is not done with
anecdotal evidence
and so you could infer a lot of stuff
from the way he expresses it but he also
communicates a lot of interesting
questions
uh
and that's something maybe you can
comment on this
you know there's certain groups that are
healthy
they have uh they're younger they have
they exercise a lot they get the all you
know nutrition and all those kinds of
things
he shows
skepticism on whether
it's
so obvious that they should get
vaccinated and the same is
he makes this he kind of presents the
same kind of skepticism for
kids
for young kids
so
with
empathy
and
uh
you know listening my russian ineloquent
description of what joe believes what
what is your kind of response to that
why should certain categories of healthy
and young people still get vaccinated do
you think well first just to say it's
great for joe to be a skeptic to ask
questions we should all be doing that
but then the next step is to go and see
what the data says and see if they're
actually answers to those questions
so coming to healthy people
i've done a bunch of podcasts besides
this one
the one i think i remember most
was a podcast with a worldwide wrestling
superstar very nice he's about six foot
six
and just absolutely solid muscle
and he got covert
and he almost died
and recovering from that he said i've
got to let my
supporters know because you can imagine
worldwide wrestling fans are probably
not big
embracers of the need for vaccines
and he want he just turned himself into
a spokesperson for the fact that this
virus doesn't care how healthy you are
how much you exercise what a great
specimen you are it wiped him out
and we see that
you know the average person in the icu
right now with covet 19 is under age 50.
i think there's a lot of people still
thinking oh it's just those old people
in the nursing homes it's not going to
be about me they're wrong
and there are plenty of instances of
people who were totally healthy with no
underlying diseases
taking good care of themselves not obese
exercising who have died from this
disease
700 children have died from this disease
yes some of them had underlying factors
like obesity but a lot of them did not
so it's fair to say
younger people are less susceptible
to serious illness kids even less so
than young adults but it ain't zero
and if the vaccine is really safe and
really effective
then you probably want everybody to take
advantage of that even though some are
dropping their risks more than others
everybody's dropping their risks some
you